Resolvamos esta
desigualdad para "p", tenemos
el valor absoluto de "
p" menos 12 más 4 es menor que 14,
entonces, hagamos esto,
un paso a la vez.
Lo primero que queremos hacer
es deshacernos de ese valor absoluto
y para hacer esto
lo que podemos hacer es,
es deshacernos de este 4 positivo
entonces, restamos 4 de ambos lados,
-4 y -4.
Así que del lado izquierdo tenemos
4 menos 4 eso es igual a 0, se cancela,
solamente nos queda
el valor absoluto de "p" menos 12,
y del lado derecho tenemos
14 menos 4 eso es igual a 10,
entonces 10,
y nos queda el signo de menor.
Así que tenemos el valor absoluto de
"p" menos12 es menor que 10,
y pensemos en esto un poco,
porque si yo te digo que el valor absoluto de...
de "x" es menor que 10
¿Eso qué significa?
Significa que la distancia de "x" al 0
debe ser menor que 10 entonces,
si yo tengo una recta numérica,
y aquí tengo, aquí tengo al 0,
solo podemos llegar a 10, de hecho, de hecho no.
10 ya es muy lejos,
debe ser siempre menor que 10,
por eso tenemos el signo
de menor estricto que 10, entonces,
esto debe ser menor que 10.
Luego podemos avanzar por la izquierda
hasta llegar a -10
y aún así no podemos incluir al 10
¿Cierto?
Entonces el valor absoluto de
"x" menor estricto que 10
podemos incluir el valor absoluto de 9
o al valor absoluto de
9.99999 pero no,
no al 10.
Entonces otra manera de escribir
esta desigualdad con valor absoluto,
es decir que "x",
"x" debe ser mayor que -10,
entonces "x" debe ser mayor que -10
y "x" debe ser menor que 10,
o podemos escribir que
"x" está entre -10 y 10,
entonces -10 es
menor que "x"
y "x" es menor que 10.
Es otra manera
de escribir lo mismo.
Esencialmente lo que estás diciendo aquí es que "
x" debe estar entre -10 y 10
pero no puede ser
-10 ó 10,
ahora ya podemos usar la misma lógica,
en el problema original
tenemos el valor absoluto de "p" menos 12,
y podemos escribirla de la siguiente manera,
entonces tenemos -10
es menor que "p" menos 12,
"p" menos 12 y "p" menos 12
es menor que 10.
Entonces podemos aislar a la "p"
que quede en medio
y para esto vamos a sumar a las 3 secciones 12,
para eliminar ese 12 que nos estorba,
entonces sumamos 12 aquí,
12 acá,
sumamos 12 acá
y nos queda
-10 más 12
¿Qué es?
Entonces,
esto es igual es igual a 2,
entonces 2 es menor que,
aquí se cancelan los 12,
nos queda simplemente "p"
y "p" es menor que 10 más 12
es igual a 22
entonces tenemos que "p" es mayor que 2
y menor que 22.
Ahora, ¿qué te parece si lo dibujamos
en una recta numérica?
Entonces nuestro conjunto solución
se mirará algo así, aquí tenemos el 2,
acá está el 22,
por acá puede estar el 0,
entonces "p" es mayor que 2,
no es mayor o igual
es mayor estricto que 2,
entonces ponemos un círculo abierto
y es menor que 22,
entonces menor que 22,
no es menor o igual,
entonces ponemos un círculo abierto
porque es menor estricto,
y será todo lo que está
entre el 2 y el 22,
de hecho lo podemos verificar
intentémoslo con algún valor que pueda funcionar,
por ejemplo el 12,
el 12 está entre 2 y 22.
Entonces "p" igual a 12,
tenemos el valor absoluto
de 12 menos 12 más 4
debe ser menor que 14
aquí tenemos 0 más 4,
debe ser menor de 14
y en efecto
4 es menor que 14, así que
funciona perfectamente
pero, por ejemplo el 0 no debe funcionar
porque no esta en nuestro conjunto solución ¿cierto?
Entonces vamos a intentarlo con el 0.
Veamos, tenemos el valor absoluto de 0 -12 más 4,
no debe ser menor de 14,
veamos,
vamos a llegar a alguna contradicción,
tenemos valor absoluto de
-12 más 4 menor que 14
y entonces 12 más 4 menor que 14,
tenemos 16 es menor que 14.
contradicción ¿cierto?
Eso el 0 no va a funcionar
porque no está en nuestro conjunto solución,
mientras que todo lo que esté
en nuestro conjunto solución si funcionará.